Hello there.
My name is Subir, and I lead the
cloud messaging team at Google.
Today, I'm going to talk
about some of the awesome APIs
that Google Cloud
Messaging or GCM provides.
GCM provides a root set
of APIs to send messages
from a server to an application
efficiently and reliably.
I want to thank all the
developers using Google Cloud
Messaging, because
it really helps
the ecosystem by minimizing
the impact your application has
on battery life, radio wake
ups, and network signaling.
Let's quickly look at some of
the APIs required to use GCM.
To use GCM, an application
needs a Registration ID.
Use this Registration
ID to send messages
to a particular device.
Multicast lets you send messages
to up to 1,000 recipients
with a single request.
And you can set Time
To Live on each request
to tell GCM went to
expire the message.
So what's new in 2014?
Today, I'll cover
three key features
that GCM provides--
XMPP-based Cloud Connection
Server, Upstream Messaging,
and User Notifications.
In 2013, we opened these APIs
to a limited set of developers.
Since then, we've added a bunch
of new features with these APIs
and made them faster
and more robust.
We saw a tremendous response
and interest from developers
around these APIs.
And I'm really
excited to announce
that these services are now
open for all developers.
Let's talk about
GCM's XMPP point,
also known as Cloud
Connection Server.
Cloud Connection
Server, or CCS, provides
a persistent, asynchronous,
bidirectional connection
to our GCM servers.
This is a very powerful
service as it provides
a virtual connection between
your server and your user's UCM
connected devices.
This connection can be used
to reliably send and receive
messages.
Here's how you can
connect to CCS.
I'm using the simple
XMPP library in Python
to connect to CCS.
As you can see,
gcm.goobleapis.com is the URL
and 5235 is the port.
You simply need to
connect to this end point
and authenticate using
your project's API key.
The next step is to
start sending messages.
These messages
include a JSON payload
that contains a target,
application data, and a Message
ID.
Since sending via
XMPP is asynchronous,
this ID uniquely identifies
an XMPP connection.
So when CCS sends an
ACK back to your server,
it will use this Message
ID to identify the message.
Therefore it is important
that this Message ID is not
only unique, but also
present in the request.
Let's take a look at what an
ACK or a NACK for this message
looks like.
Message Type would
indicate an ACK a NACK.
In case of a NACK,
there's an error code
to describe what went wrong.
So when implementing
a CCS connection,
here is what you need to know.
We allow a maximum of 100
connections per sender,
and the maximum outstanding
messages per connection
is also 100.
Our improved error
handling lets you
know more precisely
what went wrong.
Here is an example of a
control message describing
that a connection is draining.
What this message means is
that the sender should not
send any more messages
on this connection.
Any new messages
on this connection
will get back a NACK
with an error code
indicating that the
connection is draining.
We have also added new codes
for other types of errors,
like JSON parsing, et cetera.
So what we learned so far
is that with XMPP end point,
GCM provides the ability to
have a persistent, bidirectional
connection to your servers.
We also saw how to
send messages down
to a device using
this connection.
Next, we will take a look at
an awesome Upstream Messaging
API that lets you send
messages from the application
on a device to your server.
We have made a lot
of changes to make
Upstream Messaging
fast and reliable.
And I'm happy to say that it's
now open to all developers.
So let's take a look.
Since the connection between the
device and GCM already exists,
its a low latency send, as
no new handshake is needed.
These messages are saved locally
if the device is offline,
and are sent when we
have a connection.
We use the same Reliable
Message Queue technology
that we use for
Downstream Messages.
So if we lose a
connection to your server,
we will deliver the
messages once the connection
is re-established.
We will delete your
messages once we
get an ACK from your server.
A order to receive
an Upstream Message,
your server should
be connected to CCS.
Here's an example on how to send
the message using Google Cloud
Messaging APIs.
Just set the Project
ID as the destination,
and we will deliver the
message to your server.
You can send and also set
Time To Live in the API call.
This is what an ACK looks like.
Once again, since the
response is asynchronous,
Message ID is used to
identify the message.
Here are some things
to keep in mind
when using Upstream Messaging.
No pending messages on a
connection more than 100.
We will delete your messages
if your server fails
to connect for
more than 24 hours.
We will also allow a maximum
of 20 unACKed Upstream Messages
from a single device.
So ACKing is required.
And similar to
Downstream Messages,
the maximum payload size
allowed for upstream is 4K.
Here's a lot of my favorite
new APIs in GCM-- Delivery
Receipts.
When sending
messages to a device,
a common request
from developers is
to get more insight into
the state of the message
and to know if the
message was delivered.
For example, you are
writing a messaging app
and would like to
show your sender
if their message was delivered.
With CCS, you can do that now.
We are adding this new feature
called Delivery Receipts.
Here's an example on
how you can request
a receipt for a message.
In the JSON payload
of the message,
you just set the new
field Delivery Receipt
Requested to True.
By default, the value is False.
Here is a Receipt Message.
This message will
have a new Message ID.
From will be set to
gcm.google.apis.com,
and type as Receipt.
There are four fields that
we add in the response data--
message status, original
Message ID, time of send,
and the Registration ID
of the original message.
Nowadays, users have
multiple devices
and hence receive
notifications multiple times.
This can reduce notifications
from a useful feature
to an annoyance.
Thankfully, GCM provides
a convenient way
called User Notifications to
reach all devices for a user
and help you synchronize
notifications, including
dismissals.
I'll talk more about
dismissals in a bit.
With User Notifications you
can target it all devices
belonging to a user
with a single request.
This is a very
powerful API and allows
you to be smarter about
your notifications.
I'll give you a
couple of examples.
You can set a short TTL so
the notification will only
be sent to a device that
is currently connected.
Another example is to use
option of Delay While Idle.
Imagine your user
has a phone that they
use all day and a tablet
that sits idle at home.
By setting the Delay
While Idle and a TTL,
you can send the
notification only
to the phone that
is actively used.
Pretty useful, right?
To send messages to
all devices for a user,
you need a Notification Key.
The Application
Server can get a key
by adding or
removing registration
to the Notification Key name.
Let's see how you can
get a Notification Key.
Here is the endpoint to get
a key and the HTTP header.
The request is authenticated
using your project's API key.
So first thing, we add a
registration to a Notification
Key, you can do a Create.
And then if the user stores
the app on another device,
you can use an Add.
And important field is
the Notification Key Name.
For us, it's just
a unique identifier
that you use to
identify this user.
The actual username
is not relevant.
So please use a hash.
It needs to be
unique for an user.
Here's an example
of how you can send
a message to all
devices for a user.
The only difference is that
instead of sending a message
to a Registration ID, we now
send it to a Notification Key.
Now let's assume a
user on one device acts
on the notification, and
we want to dismiss this
from all other devices.
How do we do it?
With Upstream Messaging,
we can send a message
to a Notification Key and
GCM will deliver the message
to all of other
registrations in this key.
This way, you can
tell other devices
to dismiss a notification
as it is already
handled on one device.
In addition, you can
also send this message
to your Application
Server by sending
Get to a Project ID in a
separate Upstream Message.
Here is an example.
As you can see, the two
fields in the Upstream Message
is set to a Notification Key.
This will make GCM
send this message
to all other devices that
are part of this key.
User Notifications is available
on both HTTP and XMPP.
It allows a max of
20 registrations
per Notification Key.
And of course, the key
name in the request
should be unique to a user.
Before we end, I'd like you to
please check out our updated
documentation for all
GCM APIs and services.
As always, it's available
at this link here.
Thank you for watching.
And I hope you are excited
to use these new APIs
and services, and
enjoyed this video.